if I can get the guy in my mirror to
behave he can be skinny and Rich and the
way you change behavior is you change
your beliefs and the way you change your
beliefs is you get new information a new
way of looking at things you can do that
through several lenses and we've tried
to help you with all of those lenses
tonight we can go through the
intellectual lens the academic lens and
so we get two phds up here with Dr John
deloney looking at this through all the
nerd stuff and trying to get you that
way hey we can recognize our outside
foes and our enemies who's the villain
it's not
you but it is your responsibility and
George helped you with that and you can
look at it through the lens like Jade
helped us with of the spiritual and what
God's got to say about this the more
lenses that you look at your situation
through and adjust your behaviors the
more likely you are to control of this
area of your life